we live in a world of exponential
technological advancement what this
literally means that we have new
construction kits for our reality new
tools with which to probe at the
adjacent possible so consider the
implications right as Marshall McLuhan
used to say first we build the tools and
then the tools build us we are designed
by what we have designed there are these
feedback loops of mind tool and world
that radically redefined our boundaries
that radically transform what it means
to be human to be human today is to
criss cross the skies to the human today
is to create techno social wormholes and
so what do we do well we need to
radically reach out to one another in
ways that we haven't before there's a
great line that says empathy rarely
extends beyond our line of sight in
other words it's out of sight it is out
of mind but if anything is wireless
communication technologies are radically
expanding our line of sight they're
providing you want illogical maps of the
real they're giving us the astronaut
overview effect we are seeing the big
picture we are seeing the earth
Athens of spaceship earth and what shall
we do we need to extend our hands to one
another we've never had such tools to
overcome all of the limitations of our
humanity have the power to have the will
we have the capacity the creative
capacity to overcome our limits this is
today billions of us leads into one
another
note a global brain what is the new
definition of billionaire the new
definition of billionaire is he who will
positively affect the lives of a billion
people he or she will reach out and say
I would positively affect the lives of a
billion people this should be our goal
this is our responsibility here's our
chance